à chaque client la même routine
depuis ce lundi 9 août le pass and it
here est exigée à l'entrée des
restaurants uniquement pour manger sur
place une mesure plutôt comprises par
ceux qui ont pu déjeuner ce midi je la
formation ya pas mal de temps il était
quand même bien sensibilisés et moi ga
passe parce que j'ai été contaminé
donc je crée pas mal de temps
franchement si avoir une liberté de
circulation et s'assurait la santé tous
grâce à ça moi au contraire je trouve ça
très intéressant pour sarah venus
partager un repas avec des collègues le
passé même synonyme de liberté
je pense que c'est une bonne initiative
même si par rapport à certains il peut y
avoir un côté restrictif mais
aujourd'hui effectivement on peut être
on se sent beaucoup plus plus libre avec
ce passé à lesterps de pouvoir vaquer
enfin nos occupations plutôt que rester
confinés chez nous effectivement la jeu
j'ai trouvé cette période beaucoup plus
difficile du côté des restaurateurs
l'accueil lui est plutôt mitigé c'est
très contraignant pour nous voilà parce
que
on n'a pas le temps et on n'a pas envie
de faire la police en fait et mais bon
on n'a pas le choix
donc on va le faire mais c'est très
contraignant c'est pas si compliqué on a
déjà refoulé trois tables des gens qui
étaient 50% avec des passeports un sur
deux voilà donc c'est compliqué et long
puisque dès qu'on a une table de 10 le
contrôle cette fois on va dire que 40
secondes à 50 secondes par personne et
voilà donc c'est long depuis le 9 août
le pass sanitaire est également entré en
vigueur dans les centres commerciaux les
transport longue distance et les
établissements de santé